it's a beautiful night here at the
[ __ ] Voodoo Lounge the only thing
that's missing is you [ __ ] you
don't say so get you act together get
that plane ticket my girl from [ __ ]
Tucson it's coming up next week the
Indian it's gonna be scary in this
[ __ ] smoke signals for everybody
I'm saying yum Yum's for everybody we
got Jack Jr with his new head through
tonight it's all over we got edibles we
got everything we got matching Christmas
we got green ones and the red one will
starting to the [ __ ] what is it 14 days
before Chris Paul and we got [ __ ] I
got ya purple death that's what we
celebrate tonight an early Hanukkah for
you dungeon Jews you don't saying we're
going deep deep deep in the murky waters
[Music]
ah the [ __ ] mule is kicking tonight
[ __ ] if you think her piece is
may gonna come back wait you see leaf
spots
he's already green stars
spitting [ __ ] up well it don't matter we
got the [ __ ] nurse on duty there we
go we got a nutter something queer she
she's close by don't worry bud by the
time you [ __ ] pass on until I Coleman
she'll be here with some [ __ ] hard
[ __ ] memory [ __ ] I got some heart
management medication but I'll put you
right over the [ __ ] top [ __ ]
[Music]
the mule is in full effect we're going
with the big meal tonight you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey here Churchill
what's happened now the only thing
that's missing is you [ __ ]
you're what 13 days away from Christmas
the 12 days before Christmas with all 14
before Christmas and it's pre Hanukkah
so we're going deep tonight we're gonna
eat - [ __ ] a green star a red star
and 10 purples apiece look like all the
places we haven't seen before even
stabbing please over their sibling who
makes and models making a comeback they
came out for the shows in Sacramento
we don't [ __ ] around we ain't nobody
gonna hire you dawg I'm saying I can't
even this thing is so booming your
mama's got him all gummed up but I can't
even [ __ ] get it out of the bag but
it don't matter
go get out here we go here we go it's a
little funky statue hmm Oh
yum yum yum yum that's the red one
that's gonna that's the yang that's
going down mmm BAM there you go and now
starting next year on the screen during
the podcast we'll have a an edible
counter that's how we roll so there's no
misunderstandings here that's the red
one now we gotta get the green one don't
take no breaks
Rhett's are for [ __ ] we're going to
eat insane this we Chanukah Jews died so
we can walk around and you want to take
a breath you lit on fire and turn into
Jews is [ __ ] turn into shoes whatever
the [ __ ] and you don't want to eat a
[ __ ] star get that thing down our
hatch some juice somewheres in the
[ __ ] hole brain for an edible just
saving some is [ __ ] it up
is dilemmas oh [ __ ] I could taste that
little minty green THC chip poorly you
don't know we do want to countdown
tonight we're doing 10 [ __ ] stars in
two [ __ ] midgets there you go there
you go like that
no drama nobody gets their feelings hurt
oh yeah he's got a little [ __ ] dick
like Terry Crews if a [ __ ] comes flying
by he'll grab it assault force all I
still gotta [ __ ] even on the
monday and i don't think you [ __ ] with
the wrong dude mmm
who said bunkies everybody here we go
people is tremendous
here we go oh [ __ ] oh yeah we got two
tremendous weeds
we got the horse with no name and we got
hardcore og this is what they give
[ __ ] missing children to make them
remember who their parents are he's
small filipino wouldn't say you still
got it [ __ ] get you [ __ ]
together Def Leppard high and dry the
b-side you might as well hang yourself
right now you understand me like a
whirlwind girl here we go oh [ __ ]
who said bong Italy
with digging in the yang way tree so far
one down and we should install on now we
gotta start let's go ready for pocket I
want this sacred open animal
now
[Music]
one stalk and then we still gonna do ten
starter will break it on record tonight
it's Christmas week is Hanukkah he's
Jewish
the [ __ ] you gotta do what you gotta do
it's Hanukkah [ __ ]
Happy Hanukkah of all it does it Jews
out there you know I love you
[ __ ] along my heart
here we go Lee
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
you believe this show you how to put up
with all right let's go are we up
[ __ ] this is your school I'm
promoting here it's good I'm here for
five points
[Music]
[ __ ] mule deluxe you understand me
we ain't [ __ ] around no more
not even just getting oh my god I got
them that's the one that's the one oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] lights out [ __ ] just you
and me
oh [ __ ] and tongue is that type of night
if you're under 18 get off the [ __ ]
Irish Coffee little [ __ ] you
little [ __ ] then your mother
calls me telling me you having
nightmares at night uncle Joey told me
they still want to grab my sleeping
pills pointed I told you if you want to
see the devil but you're too young to
see The Devil's gonna get the light in
it shall be I'm sorry
without flopping around tonight lately
there's that spot the red animal come on
let's go cause we got to start the
podcast want a budget here you know I'm
saying what a [ __ ] budget is so
listen edibles are popular for tuam take
these are donated to us but my main man
was ghosting models boom bees your ma
knows up there holding it down and
[ __ ] wherever the [ __ ] they are in
the caves in Sacramento here we go
not bow down lay down oh [ __ ] if you got
the heroin you got my permission blast
that [ __ ] that will be door if
we do another fogging up let's check
let's do another pothead let's do the
[ __ ] the other together we don't find
you you because it's on it
[Music]
just don't flip the cigarette over right
there toilet top tremendous people I'm
over you celebrate Hanukkah single
handle these guys take a little bites
like a [ __ ] mama Luba the area is
insane
let's do it everything's on fire this
[ __ ] town
keep it this little bit I swear to God I
just open it [ __ ] bunch of smoke
taillights remember little Barnabas
[Music]
tremendous is a good night you're alive
you had a good day
we did get 22 push-ups you deserve a
little punk with uncle Joey and I'm
saying if you got your bong bust that
mother [ __ ] out and let's go beat let's
do this please Sam
Lee's up for like I had a ball in the
Hat you don't know what we're probably
there's like an edible telethon tonight
very edible we got a little kid with the
flat nose that get bullied gets $10,000
you don't say anything you get nothing
oh we're supposed to get the money no
let's go you asking me stupid questions
you're not supposed to give away the
money let's do it this is the one right
here this is the one
[Music]
is the one right here after one that's
the one that's the one that's the one
[Music]
that's the Josh's fungi toe and we we
ain't [ __ ] around somebody understand
me I put a little dead you ashes in
there
don't worry about goodbye my Lankershim
over the German deli you know Sam
Hermann the German anyway we're making
it happen
listen you asking me Joey got dates I
got an updates I'm having ear surgery
so every day is a different [ __ ]
eventuated look at Li leave in trouble
you can't believe when you get your dick
son you like a half a sperm me and
that's that no you want them to suck the
whole [ __ ] nut up right same thing
when it comes to a bunk look kid I just
felt the look easy was lump right neck I
felt like Kennedy's wife McKenna had
some brain uh neck what do you do don't
say anyway it's a beautiful night to be
alive I'm happy you guys are joining us
Def Leppard high and dry one of the best
oh my goodness your bonnet [ __ ]
I mean you clean and sober you got the
Jack and Coke that's all that matters
Jack and Coke the cigarettes boy do I
miss those days and a couple lines of
coke last time I drank Jack and Coke I
jumped the fence at the cemetery and try
to dig my mother I'd you know I'm saying
so özil to bring it to the party with me
[ __ ] it's happy hour
[Music]
please was going on ahead of what they
not eat it it's one feet away from let's
go
we got shifted doing people to speak he
thinks were [ __ ] around side
[Music]
you know every trucker for these thing
bar
oh [ __ ] that's it that's that I'm happy
you could join us tonight you know it's
just two fat [ __ ]
please rule my net little nephew Jack
sitting around clone this ain't no big
deal it ain't telling him at the
smallest man a world or the dumbest man
along Tania's I don't get the party
started but I'm saying from zero to 200
like this whether it's [ __ ] going on
man hey bro you give me a dollar in the
morning out come on with a $50 well I
got a bottle to hit somebody in the head
with a bottle
I'm over $50 let's type [ __ ] man
not too many people have that gift in
the salmon oh [ __ ] here we go take that
mewling take that meal
[Music]
that we this [ __ ] the best I told you
I got dead Jew ashes in here I got cat
ashes oh the dead Jews tremendous psyche
wanna have dumpling plays in here is
that you toes and they're grounded up
with walk is [ __ ] here we go people
here's a [ __ ] Jam this is the best
Jam on the album b-side are you kidding
me
[Music]
man
always remember you gotta hydrate when
you're messing around with THC problems
which one of those stars look let's go
you're doing well you know another fun
what's going on
you can't walk with one leg you know I'm
saying when I look at you [ __ ]
don't worry about the appendages just
keep your eyes open you want to get
raped you'll know when Cosby's flying
around yeah I'm saying yeah you are he's
doing gigs again oh man the scandalous
talk Michael Jackson - here we go oh
[ __ ]
make me blind time after time and line
by line we go take a look into my eye
here we go take a look into my eye tell
me if it's true oh you oh [ __ ]
[Music]
there you go by the puppets uncle Joey
coming directly to your living rooms
with the [ __ ] head do the Ben
Franklin LaRue down 150 tool head dude
he'll say get your [ __ ] together with
smoking [ __ ] Chanukah week tonight
[ __ ] and with Lumbee got 30
shoplifting days if I got my math
correctly
don't forget ten minutes youtube.com
slash c / Joey Diaz youtube.com slash c
/ Joey beers this periscope is sponsored
by Fuji sports.com go to Fuji the best
jeez especially for you fat [ __ ]
starting out a little Fuji in a six and
A five
get yourself with a super Ito when
you're in their guard they can pull a
bowling Bowl they got a better chance to
kill themselves and ripping that [ __ ]
geek go to Fuji Sports calm / Church CH
you are CH I'm gonna give you 10 off the
[ __ ] top I'm saying that's how I roll
concept is why cuz I love it always
respond to buy on it to the em you know
oh [ __ ] here we go [ __ ]
[Music]
and that's sitting that's that a little
to tell you on a dot-com slash Church
you start a new year you want to be
tip-top Magoo give them that eight about
eight stars and to offer brains how much
new materials that I have up our stage
that's what I'm talking about you want
to keep [ __ ] being a dunce or you
want to [ __ ] be on top of your game
alpha brain go to church go to out it
and but Church CH you are CH I'm gonna
give you ten off the top delivered to
your [ __ ] door why cuz I'm your uncle
joy and I'm looking out for you
[ __ ] that's why and that's it and
that's that one more song youtube.com
slash c / Joey Diaz alright that's a
place to be you know I love your
[ __ ] just listen to all you
Jews out there you know I love you doll
my heart I cracked a lot of jokes I call
your christ-killers but you guys taught
me how to [ __ ] it Luke
I live by your principles I don't give a
[ __ ] you understand me we roll over
anybody I don't give you show up with 12
or 13 that's what the Jews clunky
Pontius Pilate hit him saying what can
you say about that dude [ __ ] no bad
record never molested nobody
he ain't related to Harvey I'm saying we
got ourselves a good silent you there
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz happy
Chanukah to my [ __ ] desert juice I
thought I worked this out
[Music]